[Music]
welcome to Tiger belly everybody happy
new year Emperor Li here talking and I
got Guilbeau here my girl kalila and
George and we have a special guest
tonight and the special guest is Steve
what'd I tell you I already told you
that three seconds ago on your intro -
yeah yeah yeah but don't chew on [ __ ]
okay we have our my brother Steve is on
the show give him a round of applause
Eve or to start off with this um god
2017 has started off a little wrong for
me guys because I don't know how else to
say it
George sent me a dick click what a dick
flick a dick pic no no dude dude yo you
don't send guys dick pics it was a real
dick pic George George you serious yes
you want to see it yeah and also show
them it's even more disturbing that you
I'm the only one you send it to yeah
makes it's sexual in a weird way I feel
like I can already imagine what it looks
like no you don't I think it's actually
quite narrow but very long can be erect
as I said very long narrow like a noodle
it's erect in the water no oh my god
photo of him hard you got big nuts
seriously be real that's good not
student that's not--that's is dead
George you have a very big deal great
leg you have a big head your legs are
pretty we talked about his leg
look at that Sartorius muscle right
there if you see if you sent it in a
group chat that's one thing funny but
just specifically to me no no text even
even guys do the Bobby way hold on he's
so happy new years Bobby may it be
filled with joy and little surprises I
didn't get that text doesn't big
surprise that's the size of your dick
head is very like surprisingly large yes
he's at all like a tenant were you like
semi erect okay okay just just dude when
you say that's not how we imagined it at
all and in the group text Wow why did
Gilbert and I get that
[Music]